how's it going everybody it's Warren and
welcome to this week's episode of Theory
Thursdays my segment where you all
submit your theories I choose five to go
over each week and then you all vote
which one was your favorite for the week
and then the overall month the winner
takes home the monthly prize which is
currently two imax tickets so you can go
see Avengers endgame in IMAX be sure to
vote on which theory you thought was
your favorite for the month of March you
can find the video to vote in the link
above congratulations to last week's
winner Gunther S on his theory for how
the snap split the universe in two
Congrats Gunther you're now eligible to
win the monthly prize if you would like
to submit a theory of your own you can
find the email and the instructions in
the description down below
okay let's dive into some theories the
first one comes from Deepak Kumar and
Deepak has a theory on how the first
half of Avengers and games going to play
out in game starts with Tony and nebula
on the Bennet art they're playing a game
together and they're learning more about
each other's pasts then Tony records his
message to pepper meanwhile Thanos is on
Titan he is satisfied the gauntlet is
repaired and he talks to Gamora using
the soul stone he then tries to destroy
all of the stones so no one can undo the
decimation but fails and a large
explosion happens Tony and nebula
repaired the ship enough to make it back
to earth meanwhile Captain Marvel has
already met The Avengers and they plan
to go attack Thanos nebula ends up
telling them where fan OHS is rocket
tells the Avengers that he found the
same energy surge as the snap on a
distant planet which is the explosion of
fan o's trying to destroy the stones
they all go to fight Thanos except for
Tony and Bruce because Tony is injured
and Bruce still can't bring the Hulk out
The Avengers initially have the upper
hand and managed to injure Thanos but
Thanos ends up using the stones again
and he kills Captain Marvel with the
Infinity Gauntlet he then uses the space
stone to transport himself back to the
sanctuary to his ship The Avengers
return to Earth and two to three years
go by until ant-man comes out of the
quantum realm and gives the Avengers
hope with time travel
danos using the mind stone realizes what
the Avengers are about to do so he goes
and he attacks the Avengers compound a
huge fight occurs but the Avengers
manage to go back in time and from here
they will collect all of the Infinity
stones and undo the snap this theory
does make a lot of sense because it does
line up with what we've seen in the
trailers it is
very evident that the Avengers go and
fight Thanos in the beginning of the
movie and it does seem like at some
point in time they injure him but we
know they don't just defeat him take the
Infinity Gauntlet and undo the snap so
they'd most likely lose go back home and
can't do anything about it until ant-man
shows up and shows them that time travel
is possible so this theory makes a lot
of sense and could very well happen in
the movie so that's it for theory number
one onto theory number two theory number
two comes from Alfred Norwin barbacena
and he has a theory about Adam warlock
and Avengers in game Alfred says that
Adam warlock was created from the
remains of ego the Living Planet Ayesha
was able to see the genealogy of Peter
quill just by looking at him and that's
why she was curious about him as she
sends out her troops she discovers some
remains of ego the Living Planet and she
creates Adam warlock from those remains
this would make Adam warlock a celestial
and he could possibly defeat Thanos and
then take all of the Infinity stones and
become the greater threat it's
definitely possible that Adam warlock
could appear in Avengers in game yes
James Gunn said that we won't see Adam
until guardians of the galaxy vol 3 but
the Russo brothers also told us that
Avengers in game was not the title and
look where we are now and recently
Marvel released a book that is tied into
Avengers and game in Adam warlock is in
the book so it certainly is a
possibility and it would make sense that
the sovereign would be angry at whoever
did the decimation and would send out
Adam warlock to figure it out and Adam
warlock is somebody that we've all been
waiting to see in the MCU for a very
long time so perhaps the Russo brothers
thought that it's finally time to bring
him in so that's it for Theory number 2
on to Theory number 3 theory 3 comes
from Tyson Marin who has a theory about
Kang the Conqueror being in Avengers and
Game Tyson says that with all the talk
of time travel and everyone trying to
work out who the mysterious villain is
and after re-watching Avengers Earth's
Mightiest Heroes he thinks that Kang the
Conqueror will be the villain in the
next phase and the mysterious villain
that is looming in Avengers endgame
Tyson says that just like in Earth's
Mightiest Heroes Cain comes to the pass
to kill Captain America to save his own
timeline due to alterations in the past
this was due to the kree-skrull war but
Tyson thinks that in the MCU Kang's
timeline will be erased due to the
Avengers undoing the snap and altering
the timeline and this could also work
into the MCU zone secret invasion and
have
be the one who tells some of the
Avengers that some of them are not who
they think they are
ie a scroll so this theory makes sense
because we know in Avengers in game
there's going to be some time-travel and
King is the master of time-travel if the
quantum realm is the key to time-travel
then perhaps King is inside that quantum
city that we've seen from ant-man and
the wasp they didn't just put that city
in there for no purpose there's
definitely a purpose for having that
city inside of the quantum realm
perhaps King jumps three different time
periods via the quantum realm and if the
Avengers mess up one of Kang's timelines
by undoing the snap then maybe King
becomes the new villain so that's it for
theory number three on to theory number
four theory number four comes from Zion
the lion and he has a theory about
ant-man
using the time vortexes Zion says that
Avengers in game will start with ant-man
coming out of a time vortex because
ant-man suit is a prototype so he
probably can't get big so he goes out of
the time vortex at the last minute he
then ends up a little further in the
future about three weeks to a month
after the snap but Iron Man and nebula
come back to earth about the same time
when ant-man comes out of the quantum
realm but soon after Thinnes comes to
attack the Avengers and almost kills all
of them because Thanos gets a vision of
himself dying from Captain America or
Hulk wildung the gauntlet along with the
other Avengers standing in front of him
it's in the scene in the new trailer
where Thor Captain America and Iron Man
are walking up to fan OHS Danos ends up
defeating them but ant-man has his van
at the Avengers facility and goes back
into the quantum realm before he dies he
goes back inside of the quantum realm
and he finds that quantum city and
inside of the quantum city he finds
Doctor Strange Doctor Strange will tell
ant-man which time vortex to go through
that will cause their one winning
scenario to happen and at the same time
this will create the multiverse this
theory could work because I think it's a
very different play on time travel than
we all think I think most of the people
think that the Avengers will go fight
Thanos and he'll defeat them and they'll
go back to earth but why would Danos
leave the Avengers alive if he knows
they're trying to undo his plan so if
Thanos attacks the Avengers at their
headquarters and is killing the Avengers
it would make sense that a man would go
back into the quantum realm to try and
go back in time before Thanos attacks
and I do think Doctor Strange is still
going to be guiding somebody in Avengers
in game to help them go to that one
scenario where they win he
is the master of the mystic arts and it
has been mentioned lately that perhaps
everybody that has been dusted is
actually in Soul world and perhaps the
way to get there is through the quantum
realm so perhaps we could see this
theory come to light and Avengers in
game that does it for theory number four
on to the final theory number five
theory number five comes from Jordan
Irving who has a theory about the
post-credits scene for Avengers in game
Jordan thinks that in Avengers in game
we will see the scene where Fay knows
decimate Xander and in this scene he
believes that we will see Nova and from
there on out Nova will help fight
against Thanos the MCU is heading into
the cosmic future and Nova would be a
great character to introduce to the next
cosmic phase since Captain Marvel is
supposed to be leading the Avengers
after Avengers in game the post-credits
scene could be her asking Nova to be an
Avenger this does make sense because the
MCU is supposed to be heading into the
cosmic future after phase 3 and Kevin
Feige has been hinting a lot at Nova and
not to mention the Russo brothers have
said that there are going to be
characters that we have not seen in the
MCU that are from the comics in Avengers
in game so this could be Nova that
they're talking about which would make
sense because Thanos did go decimates
and are and in theory Nova should be
there to help protect it
so perhaps Nova dies and the Nova force
gets transferred to somebody or perhaps
Nova escapes somehow and regroups with
the Avengers or the Avengers could even
go back in time to right before Thanos
attacked and warn Nova about Thanos so
that's it for this week's theories let's
do a quick recap so you can vote on your
favorite one theory number one is how
the first half of Avengers and game will
play out the Avengers will go fight
Thanos and Thanos will kill Captain
Marvel the Avengers go back home and
then two to three years later ant-man
comes out of the quantum realm and then
the Avengers go back in time to collect
the Infinity stones theory number two is
that the sovereign will send out Adam
warlock to see who caused the decimation
Adam warlock will help defeat Thanos and
then possibly get the Infinity Gauntlet
and become the new threat theory number
three is that Kang the Conqueror will be
the new threat and Avengers in game The
Avengers mess up Kang's timeline so he
goes back in the past to try to fight
the Avengers and fix his own timeline
theory number four is that a man will
come back through a time vortex
Thanos then attacks the Avengers
headquarters and right before ant-man is
about to die he goes back inside of the
Kwan
he then midst dr. strange who tells him
exactly which time vortex he needs to go
through for the one winning scenario to
happen
and theory number five is that we will
see the decimation of Xander and
Avengers end game along with Nova
becoming an Avenger in the post-credits
scene so that is it for this week's
theories for Theory Thursday be sure to
vote on which one you thought was your
favorite and again don't forget to vote
on who you think should be the winner
for March you can check out the video to
vote in and the link above and again if
you want to submit your own theory for a
chance to end up in an episode of Theory
Thursdays you can find the email to send
it to and the instructions in the
description down below again don't
forget to vote on which Theory you think
should be the weekly winner and don't
forget to subscribe so you can stay up
to date on everything relating to
Avengers in game and all things Marvel
thanks for joining me here on Theory
Thursdays and as always thank you all so
much for watching Wolf Wolf the fight of
our lives he's pretty good that right
Avengers and Game
[Music]
you